these kinds of roles
you see and all of those are in high
demand not just within science and
engineering but within media and
Communications and medicine and consumer
products and I think you guys already
know this and that's why you're here
um
whenever trying to build new
competencies around Ai and machine
learning and advanced development
you need to have
a lot of different skills this is not
just a field that has one particular
skill
and some of these you're going to be
exposed to are
skills that are methods and skills that
are around certain software and and the
libraries
statistics as as a you know it's just
it's our
um
we're going to give you a background in
more of that and understanding
probability a little bit of linear
algebra
python we're going to be doing a lot of
coding in
over on the far side if you see numpy
numpy is the one of the science and math
libraries for Python and
that's used extensively in in the work
that we do in Caltech
um and and not just our group of course
the the larger Institute if you go to
the numpy website there are two case
studies that you'll see on their home
page uh one is
how they use the tools within that
particular package to do the Imaging of
the Black Hole uh m87 by Dr Katie
Bowman's group Dr Bowman lives in my
building right here uh here on campus
her team
worldwide
worked on the Imaging of m87 I think in
2019
other case study you'll see there is for
ligo which is a gravitational wave
Observatory that was also invented
initially theorized and invented here at
Caltech uh by Kip Thorne who got a a
Nobel Prize
um so these are the kinds of tools and
skills that you can use in any kind of
commercial business but also if you're
in science and engineering
um that really want to do breakthrough
things
um
and we're going to help you get there
I'm gonna stop right now we want to get
a sense of uh who you are and and what
is it that you're looking for and spirit
can you help with the poll
yeah I've got the pole open now for
people on WebEx if you're watching on
the streaming services you can put your
answers into your comment or chat boxes
and
we'll leave the poll open for about
another 20 seconds
and this is really to ask you about why
it is that you haven't yet
found a program like this that fits your
your needs why you haven't done this
taking that step yet
um
select one two three
or all four of the reasons
depending on what what applies to you
and
here's the result
the streaming people can't necessarily
see it but um
sixty percent of the audience says I
don't have the kind of practical
exposure and experience that makes them
feel confident
that
they can claim to be an AI and MML
practitioner and then 43 say they can't
find a program that has a comprehensive
curriculum so
Mike will start the discussion about
that
yeah the
um
so that's important it's not necessarily
a surprise because we've developed this
program along with simply learn in order
to meet the needs of the of those issues
um are there free resources that are out
there
um from other platforms or on YouTube or
even edx even Caltech edx
can you learn that way absolutely is it
the best way to do that and reinforce
learning through practice
it can be a bit inefficient
um but
what we do in this program is use that
flipped classroom model that we're going
to give you and you'll be able to work
through projects
during that you'll have access to the
platform at all times
um and it's set up in this way to also
meet the demands of people who are fully
employed
um who are either looking to create new
skills
that work invest some time to upskill
what they're doing you may have a little
bit of background in in machine learning
and Quant type tasks
uh you might already be an Excel jockey
this is going to take you to the next
level
but we do it to try to help you fit the
demands that you have in your life
already
um at the end uh you'll get a
certificate from Caltech like I said
this is about six months there's a
culminating kind of project if you had a
Capstone which we'll talk about in a
minute
um when you've successfully completed
everything
there's not a necessarily a test at the
end but there are certification steps
along the way
you also
be able to access some elective courses
um we've teamed with IBM to offer
um kind of a deep dive into python for
data science
in this you'll be able to
join in some master class sessions which
are monthly with either a Caltech
instructor also an IBM instructor and do
ask me anything sessions you have any
kind of question bring those up
understand how they are applying machine
learning in different cases and
scenarios
in the end you'll also get what are
called CEUs these are continuing
education credits this is important for
employ
lawyers who may be reimbursing you for
tuition they might be funding this
program for you this is a very common in
the US I think most people on this call
this
pretty
particular boot camp is for a US
audience
um the CEUs that you're going to get
you tell your employer about that you
show them the dates of the program and
that's how they'll typically uh fund the
tuition for you 22 CEUs converts to 220
Active Learning hours that's why it's a
six month program 10 to 15 hours every
week
the 22 or 220 hours that's just Active
Learning that's the amount of content
that you have and then the lessons if
you're doing stuff on your own that's
even extra time so as you think about
putting this program into your in your
live uh you need to plan around it
um the live sessions are meant for you
to be there
you need to engage in order to get the
most out of this so this is an
investment and you're going to be
greatly rewarded so with a certificate
you get the continuing education credits
you can join our private LinkedIn group
for all the Caltech ctme grads and
certificate holders
and then we'll also have a a
complication event online where you can
be a part of that experience or that
may be recognized in for certain Awards
all right
um
you probably know who Caltech is just in
case you don't uh this is the California
Institute of Technology we've been
around since 1891 and we're a science
and engineering uh private Institution
with engineering and applied sciences
which is my division that's where we are
that includes everything from computer
math Sciences electrical engineering
civil engineering structural
aerospace engineering and so on and
medical engineering we also have physics
math and astronomy
you may be familiar with the jet
propulsion lab or JPL we run that for
NASA
there's
bio and bioengineering chemical and
chemical engineering and Humanities and
guess what machine learning is used in
every single one of those fields every
single one of those disciplines in
academics and in profession so what
Caltech does is excel at
taking computer and math sciences and
computational thinking
match it up with a field and really
Drive kinds of brand new results
and
we've chosen to create these kinds of
boot camps to help
intermediate learners
uh
build out new ways to help Advance their
careers and and do it in a way that's
kind of very fun and instructive
on this particular program I already
mentioned we teamed up with IBM
they're going to be providing some of
the content
um
earlier I said this is an intermediate
class if you are just beginning
um and you have
they're fresh out of school you don't
have a lot of work experience
if you've got a programming background
it could be a python could be JavaScript
Java
um C plus plus the more you have of that
the better
but you need to have some background in
that and statistics to to join this is a
program that's also designed for adult
Learners we need people who've you met
you don't have to go to college but at
least be out of
out of high school
um and if you've got work experience
that's even better because then you can
understand the context for how some of
these things are going to be implied so
those are really the prerequisites
so uh Stuart we've got another poll on
people's experience level
yeah related to that last slide
um just like to get a feeling for uh the
level of experience of folks in the
audience
how much experience do you have in the
workplace not necessarily an AI and ml
just general working experience
it's open for about three more seconds
and
it's a kind of a split distribution so
you have 40 of the audience but two
years or less
almost 40 percent 10 years or more so
it's the
interesting program because it addresses
both of those levels of skill so
our levels of experience
yeah for the for the people who are
putting in more than 10 years uh
put it put in chat what kind of roles do
you have I'm so it's not that we I've we
haven't seen this kind of distribution
before but I'm interested in the kind of
roles that people have had
um were they in development or were they
in general business or something else
um I'll just I'll look at the chat a
little bit later but would love to get a
sense of
um where folks come from
that's great uh so
if you were coming into the program and
you need a little bit of
uh remedial work you haven't been
exposed to python you're going to have
the the ability to to get some of that
uh through some of the uh this
particular course if there are other
things that you need Stuart can also
recommend some to you but we'll talk
about how the program really prepares
you so at this point I'm going to turn
it over to Stuart let him walk through
those
okay
thank you Mike I'm going to go ahead and
take the uh control of the slide deck
okay
I'll be showing from my side
and here we go
uh we'll talk about how the how the
program prepares you and
um
we'll do a description of the learning
environment
the learning environment is online it's
delivered through your device
most of the time you'll be using
a laptop or desktop web browser
because you'll want to be able to see
more of the real estate while you're
going through
uh programming examples that type of
thing very difficult to do on a handheld
device but you can use your handheld
device to do the
um
preparation work looking at the
pre-recorded video components of the
program that get you ready for each
class section the class sections happen
on the weekends and two for our
sessions one on Saturday one Sunday and
this is a live virtual classroom
environment
Mike said uh flipped classroom where
um you're all watching the instructor
and interacting with uh instructor live
um you're also able to interact with
your peers in the class
um through chat and
you're able to follow along with do the
exercises with the instructor and ask
your questions live in that session
that will set you up for the work you do
in the rest of the week
labs and projects that you do again in
the same learning management system
environment on a
Jupiter lab platform
gives you access to all the tools and
libraries that you need to do the
projects and Labs does the assessments
keeps track of your progress through the
course
and as you go through each step of the
curriculum which we'll talk about in
just a second
you unlock
the next course as you complete the one
you're in so finishing one course lets
you then move on to the next in the
sequence
this is important because the sequence
is designed to build up your set of
skills in stepwise fashion so that
you're prepared for the material by the
previous courses you took It All Leads
up to a Capstone project
um we'll talk more detail about that in
a few moments but that's where you work
with your instructor as a mentor and you
get to solve a an industry aligned
problem
and create a solution that you can then
add to your personal portfolio
example of your actual working
experience in the field so
along the way the learning environment
includes
better support tools
your ability to interact with the
instructor
your set of files
recorded videos including recordings of
class sessions that you may have missed
um so if you
you have to miss the
live class on the weekend you know a few
times you'll be able to catch up with
those with the recordings there is a a
requirement
attend a certain percentage of the live
classes in person so
do you have to commit to being able to
do that program you also have access to
uh simply learned support staff who can
help you with either the course material
or with technical issues if of any
difficulty
using the platform so all of that is
available to you 24 7. that means that
other than the scheduled times for the
live classes you can do all the work on
your own schedule at whatever time
you have available
talk about the curriculum and how it's
built up
begins with an orientation session that
gets you oriented to what you're going
to learn and how to use the learning
management system and then it takes you
through the the basic steps of
introduction to artificial intelligence
and then getting familiar with the
Python language
python for data science and then
applications of python in data science
and then it moves into the machine
learning
modules that take you into machine
learning and then deeper into
the topics of machine learning including
Machine Vision
um and deep learning
after you've finished those six core
courses
after the orientation session there are
six core courses and then you can move
into the Capstone project again
about a three to four week effort with
your instructor as a mentor
taking you through a a live industry
application
creating your own solution and then
upon the successful completion of the
Capstone it's evaluated as
[Music]
deserving
Merit then you get your certificate from
Bell Tech along the way you have the
ability to take
various electives which are at no
additional cost which uh you can take
based on your
time availability and your level of
Interest so you can
go deeper into statistics for data
science you can go into natural language
processing and speech recognition
[Music]
um
look at reinforcement learning and then
you have a series of Caltech master
classes
that are taught by the structures from
Caltech ctme and delve into deeper
topics of what's going on in the
industry and what new areas are emerging
in ainl
there's also the as we mentioned before
the IBM
amas and master classes that you're you
have access to
especially around the python
modules
and so this curriculum takes you
as I said step by step towards Mastery
of AI and ml
along the way you learn
how to use and you actually use various
tools and platforms
at plot live the
numpy Library
various other
tools for machine learning like Keras
and tensorflow all of these
you get hands-on experience with
you do the labs and projects using the
tools tools are made available to you
through the learning management system
so you don't have to search for and
download anything else this gives you
uh real practical hands-on experience
with
these tools and platforms so that when
you put on your CV yes I've used Django
and a Keras and tensorflow you can back
that up with examples of the work you've
done with them
and then
one last word about the Capstone
projects again
the Capstone project you get to choose a
real life industry problem to solve
something that you would expect to be
given by an employer when you're
employed as a AIML engineer or developer
um you can choose it from different
industry domains like Commerce or
entertainment that type of thing but you
then
get to design and Implement Your
solution
you have your instructor meeting with
you weekly to review your progress make
sure you don't get into any dead ends
um keep you on track then at the end you
show off this project
it's evaluated as your final project in
the
camp and it's what earns you that final
certificate because it demonstrates
your Mastery of all of the topics and
skills that covered in the boot camp so
if you can do this Capstone project
that's
an excellent indicator that you have
mastered the material in it and do the
work in the real world so it's really a
great aspect of the program but it also
gives you something that you can show
off
the future employers because it goes
into your get portfolio so that you're
able to take it with you after the end
of the boot camp
um Mike's colleague Rick Hefner is the
Global program advisor
or he's the program advisory he happens
to be the the head of Caltech ctme
and
um so it looks like Mike and Rick and
the other instructors and subject matter
experts
um this program
gives you the benefit of the Caltech
ctme
infrastructure and expertise
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
here
the people come into this program from a
bunch of different angles it doesn't
all comes from Information Technology or
software development
manufacturing people like Boeing
um Pharma Health Care
[Music]
um
all of the different
sectors of the
economy in the industry
need to deal with the flood of data from
a increasingly Digital World which means
they need automated tools using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
handle that data so you're going to be
in this program with peers who are
employed
by a wide variety of different
[Music]
organizations around the world
and you know get to
pick up
[Music]
um
what's going on in their Industries and
their sectors
and it'll be a great way to create
networking
we have several reviews from Learners
these are available on the website for
the uh program for the boot camp so I'm
not going to read them to you but the
the
reviews do you talk about how
you can start from a very basic
understanding and go all the way into
the
depths of election winter says deep
learning and tensorflow
and
uh
will give you the uh URL for the course
page that you can see some of these
and then uh I would like to talk about
career assist service which is important
because
presumably you're all interested in
developing Ai and ml skills
Mastery so that you can pursue new
avenues in your career some of you may
be doing that for your current employer
some of you may be looking to start a
new career or change employers
what simply learned offers is a set of
services for Learners in the US this is
us specific and it gives you access to
ongoing
continuing education opportunities with
simply learn
um also builds up your portfolio with
the Capstone project and other projects
that you do in the boot camp but there's
also a specific job assist Services
through Talent Inc Talent Inc offers a
three-part set of services the first is
access to a job portal which gives you a
kind of a private environment look at uh
sets of jobs and apply for those without
revealing yourself in the public
domain through other platforms like
indeed or
dice might do
so you get to
look at a
wide range of jobs coming in
and do it in a confidential manner
um for your resume this is extremely
important because uh in today's world
most resumes go through an automated AI
bot
that does your first evaluation of the
resume matches it to the requirements
set up by the employer and the job
description
so you need to have your resume in a
format
that actually
fits with that process and will get past
that automated system
understanding how to format the resume
how to create different sections of it
and what types of wording will get you
through that process
critically important and so that gets
you
[Music]
um
two rounds of rewriting your your resume
with a professional
to make it
compatible with the AI pre-screening and
attractive to the humans who will see it
thereafter
finally one-on-one interview service
which is important for anybody whether
they're looking for a new job or not
um if you're looking to get promoted
you're going to go through a series of
interviews as well uh internally and if
you're looking to get a new job you'll
go through a series of interviews with
even more layers
um
every job change requires
more than one
interview
[Music]
round with
people who are going to be evaluating
your technical skills and evaluating
your team fit with their organization
and the interview prep allows you to put
your best foot forward in both of those
environments you get to practice what
it's like to be questioned about
technical issues subject matter but also
what it's like to be interviewed about
soft skills and cultural fit so
this is a valuable aspect of the service
regardless of whether you're changing
careers or looking to get promoted
so with that I'm going to talk about the
ongoing series of webinars that we do
today's webinar is a program preview and
it's specific to one of the
Caltech programs
that we offered
simply learn as an organization also
does a series of free
webinars that cover technology topics
overviews of the industry
Master Class
examples of deep dives into a particular
technology or
lab exercise we also cover
job search techniques
however how to care and feed your
um career as a whole and how to to keep
your career on track so all of these
things are available to you as simply
learn Caltech alumni
oh
and then we talk about the projects so
projects within this person then you can
also review these on the website for the
uh
for the boot camp but these are the
types of domains that you'll be working
in and developing projects in social
media e-commerce Manufacturing
Ed Tech and Healthcare different
examples of
domains and live industry aligned
problems that you you'll have the
opportunity to to create the solution
for so
again this is how you build up a
portfolio that you can then show off and
say I have done this work
um I have hands-on experience in Ai and
machine learning
confidence that I can do it for you as a
as my employer
so with that I am going to ask
one more question
based on what Mike has shared with you
and what I just described
um are you interested at this point
enrolling in this boot camp
again if you're watching the streaming
audience uh go ahead and put an answer
into your chat or
comment box
keep this open for another 10 seconds
close the poll now
so three quarters of our audience are
interested in uh
enrolling in this boot camp
which is very gratifying
I'm going to share with you the actual
process of enrollment
the steps are very straightforward
you basically submit an application
through ask us at simplylearn.net so
right after this webinar if you send an
email to ask us at simplylearn.net
you'll be able to get instructions on
what to submit for your application
uh after that Caltech and simply will
review that application to make sure
that you have the qualifications the
aptitude succeed in this program
and then we'll send you an admission
letter
your
applications accepted
we'll talk about the next upcoming
cohort cohorts start periodically
the next one happens to be coming up in
a week October 13th is the welcome
session
the classes start on the weekend of
October 29th
and
the cost of this program is a U.S
audience program
eight thousand dollars
you can enroll from other countries but
the price will be the same
it can be financed at 704 dollars a
month that's zero interest financing
as Mike mentioned many employers offer
tuition reimbursement if this is
something that applies to your current
position or something that will help you
uh move up within your employer company
you can ask your employer about their
policies on tuition reimbursement
whether they will pay for the course or
whether they will reimburse you for the
course once you've completed it
um very important to know and
if you hurry if you want to sign up for
the cohort where the welcome session is
October 13th and the classes start
October 29th there is an incentive
um we would ask you to
ask the folks that ask us at
simplylearn.net about the incentive for
signing up for the October 13th cohort
of the AI and ml boot camp
and they will let you know what your
bonuses for attending this live preview
today
so
um
recommend that you make that uh send
that email right after the session here
get the information and see if this is
the right program for you
so we've reached the point now where we
can do questions and answers and I am
going to stop sharing the screen
so that Mike and I can take your
questions
yeah I tried to answer some of these
along the way
um while you were speaking Stuart
excellent so you can give me a guide to
see which ones yeah
um
so I'm gonna take a couple of them
that uh
I've seen here we have a question from
Alejandra can the program be customized
somehow and the answer to that Alejandra
is that the the customization would be
in what electives you take
um you do have to take the the core
courses in order to earn the boot camp
certificate so can't deviate from that
um but you can
um
and do the work on your own schedule so
that's another level of customization
but you do have to um
some third things are standard like
attending the classes
uh we have
yeah Alejandro's question was if if
you're adding on technical components
like there's another package that I want
to understand
[Music]
um I'm doing some agile releasing and I
need to understand that a little bit
more that's one thing like what story
said is you can add those on separately
if you're going to try to customize to
take the program in a different
direction that then we need to talk
about that because that's not how the
program's design yeah we've had people
ask in the past about taking
uh taking it at an accelerated rate and
uh maybe doing two courses at once or
that type of thing and that's not a
practical way to take this program you
do have to kind of follow the sequence
in order to make sure that you get the
uh material
in the right
sequence and master it so that you can
move on to the next course
um yeah Aaron asks Eric python whiz who
could you can definitely accelerate
those things but if it's if it's brand
new don't try to yeah
um bathroom when the when are the
classrooms hosted uh generally do we as
I mentioned Saturdays and Sundays four
hours each day
um as the live class schedule what Prem
asks what a percentage of attendees pass
of course
um our general uh ass rate with our
boot camp programs is a well over 90
percent
um we're very proud of that
um the reason for that is that
we are very upfront with your
expectations about what your commitment
is to to the time that you have to put
into the program and then the learning
management system does certain things
um like remind you if you have missed a
class or remind you if you have an
upcoming project that's due it will send
prompts to you it may send reminders to
your instructor to let them know to talk
with you and help you get back on track
so the the way we designed the program
and the Learning Management platform
to maximize
completion rate and satisfaction with
the program because
um
if you don't complete the boot camp and
get the result that you want then
you're not going to be happy we're not
going to be happy because we will have
created as a degree in global education
that's how did this program this month
from Eric
um the cohorts tend to start every maybe
every two months so you'll be able to
check and send the
question to ask us at simplylearn.net
they will be able to give you
um more complete course schedule on the
website which I will put into the chat
right now
um there are
the next
two
cohorts including this
current coming one in the one after
but let me put that into the chat for
you
you can
there we go
there you have the email address as well
as the
um
URL for the course page
talked about the the cost of duration
what percentage of students advance to a
career in AIM and ml
um
you can ask it ask us simplylearn.net
about the placement success
um again this is not a job guarantee
program we offer you career assistance
to help maximize your your likelihood of
getting a job but we don't guarantee
that you will but
um again with a high
rate of first of uh program completion
uh and with the demand for Professionals
in the industry uh the the placement
rate is very good so they do have
statistics on that
um
uh I'm not seeing any other questions
Mike have you seen other questions that
you want to address right now
um
you know to go back to this one of
um
uh when people complete the program so
the lectures
we'll we'll stop at a at a certain day
right
um but this idea is that the end of the
program you still have time to complete
a project you're working on your
um on your Capstone you're documenting
it you're putting it together to be able
to show off in in GitHub you might be
making this man sorry kind of
presentations about it
um
and you want all that to work you're
still going to get reviews on that so
when I look at when people complete the
program they some might get it all done
within five months
some you know it ends at six months but
they need like extra weeks there's not
an end real cut off time I've had some
people spend about a year on their
program
um but they we are really trying to set
you up for success and you have access
to the instructory of the Tas 24 7
support on the platform
um we we want you to succeed and so
people
you know finish all their requirements
and and everything at different times
yeah almost like when I'd look at it
it's like rolling dates almost
um
so hopefully that's that kind of
flexibility is something that that you
need we believe you do and and you know
what we've seen over the last few years
with with covet and either people still
working at home or people trying to
change you know you have demands in your
life that require flexibility and we're
trying to bring that to you
uh and also you also bring up you
reminded me to mention that talk about
the career assist service which wouldn't
be all that useful if it started on
day one and ended when you got your
certificate it actually extends for six
months after you earned your certificate
from the boot camp so
um you have access to those
career assist Services resume and job
board and interview prep
um for that extra six months when you're
actually
God they actually got your certificate
and your Capstone project in hand and
ready to show it off
got that that helped get you out in
front of employers and put your best
foot forward so I did want to mention
that
so you can feel confident that you are
supported in your job search
for an extended period after the end of
the boot camp
um
and
I think with that I think that
all the questions we happen to have in
the moment let me double check
there's any that have come in
haven't seen any from our online
audience so
um I'll go ahead and ask the final poll
question if I may
did you want to add anything Mike
nope go ahead
wrong window okay
foreign
a little bit
so the last full question
now that you heard the full story
um and if you are interested in
joining
enrolling for the program when would you
like to do that
something that you want to do for that
uh October cohort something that you
might want to do
um the one after that or is it something
that you look at more long-term
we always say that if this is something
that's going to improve your life and
your career
why not do it right away so
cheer
and we'll close the poll
the result is 40 of the folks in our
audience are interested in joining
immediately again when you email ask us
at simplylearn.net ask about the
incentive for joining the October uh
cohort
um
we have 25 percent who say that they'd
like to do this within three months so
maybe the
uh nexco part after October and
the
room we're looking at longer term be
assured that the program will be
available to you
um whenever you are ready to take that
step so
we certainly want to welcome you into
the Learning Community with Caltech
and
simply learn and
I want to thank you very much for being
here
I think Mike for taking us through the
program and sharing with us the Caltech
perspective
um I will do
one last entry into the chat box of the
URL and the email address
there it is
so you have that available and with that
thank you all very much email us at ask
us at simplylearn.net for more
information and we thank you for being
here that concludes this webinar so
have a great rest of your day
thanks everybody
thank you
thank you Mike
here we go